oui c'est vrai je suis très ému et très
fier aussi pour la loire-atlantique
avoir réussi à gagner deux sièges de
renouvellement je pense que cette
bienvenus bienvenue pour tous les élus
de loire atlantique qui socialiste qui
ces derniers temps désespéré un peu et
donc on reprend on reprend vie et on
redémarre
c'est quoi c'est également la
reconnaissance pour vous du travail
accompli lors du précédent mandat
c'est beaucoup de choses peut-être que
c'est le travail en tout cas je le dis
bien modestement mais je suis convaincu
que les valeurs que je représente et que
je vais à nouveau défendre sont celles
qui ont peut-être touché et répondu au
mieux aux élus de loire atlantique
est ce qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui que
là c'est un peu le retour de la gauche
dans ce territoire
dans ce département de loire atlantique
après des législatives où la république
en marche avait fait complètement le
grand chelem sur les dix sièges de
députés oui les élections de
un dernier 1
exemple les forces
qui sont les miennes des valeurs qui
sont les miennes la gauche en général et
donc là on reprend on reprend pied
c'est un bon un bon signe en tout cas je
le prends comme ça je suis ravi merci